hey guys it's now from the score eSports
symbol is one of the best players in
csgo but being the best doesn't mean
being the best to me like you shut the
[ __ ] up
stop talking with someone playing you
beach beach however simple has come a
long way especially since joining Navi I
don't know what I learned
shouldn't be MP on your team there are a
lot of respect for your teammates I
learned how to be always come come
you know because I know for myself if
I'm so emotional in game I'm gonna play
very bad gonna lose with his unique
style and creative play simple gave the
world a glimpse of what was yet to count
from falling off kills to throwing offs
here's the VESA simple smokes see a
couple smokes in the same place
this guy is simple I don't know man it
comes in with that one button there was
no soon made sure does have a lot of
often under smoke so it could be really
rough for several times to get through
this he's gotta throw the if it is that
that's you can't say that that's a fake
what you've basically done to everyone
playing Counter Strike for the next
three weeks is everyone is gonna be
throwing up so the walls now thanks for
that it was just like hey you know she's
like what the [ __ ] is going on
look towards that ramp ego great the
long waits of simple headshot to sixer
no scope to art BK and another absolute
madman that first shot is insane the no
scope to follow up easy as you like it
this guy's on fire he only has the sees
that he's had cut to nail all right he's
got to get the gun now that he's got the
gun and with Guardian on six HP this
could be brilliant yeah absolutely could
be the fact he's found that kill now he
has armor and the bomb down Guardian
reveals that he's coming from I mean low
HP easy as simple wool coat back towards
the rear of the APC it even comes TT
simple against himself three though oh
there it is four and five fine
improvement
hey thanks gonna get posted this time
he's gonna challenge hitting missus
again close range
she gets a shot on apex jumping oh my
god taking down n BK that's outrageous
talk I I'm sure he would have probably
said that you know watch out for
connector same pole what's going on
three ones house with the USB because
why not
here at me as well simple is gonna try
respond though good position to swing in
that and four simple simple thing commit
to the plant no makes it out smartly
Soviets Edward if he knows that they're
trying to wrap back around onto him
smoke to allow him the freedom of
movement and also the chance to pee
spots of the gun barrel love Zeus he's
gonna try and catch him out lurk up
closely sees him coming night shot by
simple there's two one to go
[Music]
goes in one versus three essentially in
the site simple good boy go down goes
nifty 10 seconds and simples aware of
the time backs off accordingly jay-z
walking's just gets taken down anyway
right then both of them in front of
simple creeping in he's gonna get one
that I shot to it oh my god
simple clutching the round Edwards could
be ready and waiting simple vote just
doesn't seem to care much he's throwing
the rulebook counter-strike away and
he's completely lighting them up this is
unbelievable simple with their head
shots from how simple their with the AWP
taking down rain first next in line is
all of my sir but I kept saying oh my
god simple taking down Guardian it's
gonna be a hard day for the backers
everybody here is wild simple light some
over to our third is well Todd it all
fell apart for now one pixel spot sees
it coming he gets very very close-up
claim he's there as well and simples
here to deny the ball play that's his
whole job and he's gonna do it he gets
two kills
JDM clotheslines
filthy with it but a simple apparent
Authority that's three that's sexy serum
simple right there could he make it or
of course he can takes the time in the
position by simple rotates so you see
that rocks by the dinging snap believe
or simple takes down rain it's so quick
and he's gonna drop Kerrigan as well
it's in Paul versus happy and one on one
happy with the ak-47 simple with the AWP
at the don't smoke hole at this stage Oh
simple that's gonna be a straight kill
on what's that he's got no chance at all
to electronic watch for simple he's got
the scout oh my god how fast was that I
didn't think there was a chance in hell
e at the shot but it is simple he nails
it it wasn't missing look just falling
off my wife no still in the animation of
jumping and somehow nails the shot Sonny
simple is there with the AWP and they
could fall back take the man make that a
two-man Avanti simple just trying to
style on the Danes third yeah seems I
right now these guys are wake it up
simple splashed he wants to go in
football what are you doing that's a
really beneficial approach and so is
that oh my god leaves for the bomb plant
in the one on three very nearly under
facts
please
Phil ready and bit straight away but
simple his head to save the day b250 out
in shock
he will return but he looks the wrong
way and simple of continued a dance the
sound son as he steps left steps right
steps now he'll say meat seafood shop
stays we're facing sruthi spawn but he
knows he's on the rotation he make a
pickup and in the fat boy he and he
knows the last player is rotating fruits
he's poor and simple go speak with the
first kill and Zeus needs to step up as
well as hell DLC continued to push the
bomb drop to 15 seconds left
there are time for this and simple is
just completely our system on the site
four kills put some up by one
gahbeeg tries to get aggressive perfect
timing on the repeat from simple hit
blink market still peeking long as well
show me a quick turnaround from zeus and
simple simple first up the back quickly
headshot rpki quickly followed up a
little or the next the best as well at
this point out of the way this now I can
do myself
I've got whatever I want I can do these
spots the other toward the dumpster and
then banks tears both didn't get the
first shot off it has the information to
more good headshots where's the kills
from Navi there aren't any it's simple
in a 1vs5 he's down to Joey's got a turn
all headshot he better show up doesn't
fully commit to the shoulder simple
knows he can get closer and closer but
also knows toward the door is where the
other player is just perfectly baited
through exactly what was going to happen
and simple he's holding it close enough
angle that the OP shouldn't be a factor
only way that is if it came up mid if it
followed simple all the way around the
map it's not if he's gonna get closer
and closer simple sees it and simple
capitalizes a 1vs5 define map point to
bail out Navi
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]